good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have something special that when you
unleash it it will be able to change the
world so to help you on your journey
today's message is aim high over to you
george RR martin and i started actually
reading a science fiction novel that had
been an idea and playing with a long
time book called avalon and i was
working on avalon and it was coming
pretty well and suddenly the first
chapter of game of thrones came to me
where they find the dire wolf pups
[Music]
it's a freak
it's a direwolf I knew it wasn't part of
the science fiction not while I was
writing this was clearly a fantasy
medieval had these wolves and this large
family I'd been reading a lot of
historical fiction em I've been in the
back of my mind but suddenly it all
gelled and I wrote and I wrote that
chapter in like two three days it just
came to pour out of me goats stop there
are five pups one for each of the stark
children the direwolf is the sigil of
your house they were meant to have them
we'll train them yourselves you'll feed
them yourselves and if they die you will
bury them yourselves
when I did return the books I said to
myself okay I've had many things option
they never make them I've done pilots
and TV shows tried to keep them within
budget and producible and ever make that
I'm tired of playing that game I'm gonna
you know I have a big imagination I have
an epic story I want to tell I'm gonna
make it as big as my imagination I'm
gonna have all the the castles and
battles I want I'm gonna have hundreds
of characters because the real world is
complex I want my fictional world to be
complex too not as kind of simplified
thing I want to have giant battles I
want to have incredible castles that
each one is distinct from the other that
people remember for all time I want to
have dragons and direwolves and mammoths
and a wall of ice at 700 feet tall I
want something huge and epic that could
stand up there with token
a funny thing happens when you start
setting bigger goals from yourself where
you start imagining a bigger future
potential for yourself you start to
accomplish bigger things most people
have really really small goals for
themselves and when they hit it they're
happy they hit their goal and then they
said another really small goal for
themselves and they continue to live
small and they continue to play small
because their thinking is small because
their ambitions are small and as long as
you're happy that's great that's fine
but I think if you have the ability to
do more than you have the responsibility
to do more as well and I would encourage
all of you to think how can I do
something bigger how can I have a bigger
goal for myself how can I stretch myself
to do a little bit more than what is
comfortable for me I look at my overall
goal I want to help a billion
entrepreneurs I want up a billion
entrepreneurs in my lifetime like how
does that happen a lot of people look at
that goal and they say well that's
impossible it's never gonna happen a lot
of people say well how do you track it
are there even a billion entrepreneurs
out there in the world and the people
who think like that the people who come
from that world of scarcity they think
small they are not out doing amazing
things you need to avoid those people
those people are like a disease they're
small thinking can be a disease too
you there doubt their negativity their
small thinking can seep into you to
shrink yourself down you want to go off
and do this amazing thing but then all
the people around you are negative and
what they're doing is pulling on you and
they pull you right back down to where
you were because you don't want to be
judged by them because you don't want to
disappoint them because you don't want
to fail in front of them that's toxic
and you may not be able to totally
eliminate those people from your life
like maybe that's your mom and maybe
there's a lot of great things about your
mom but but this piece you don't like so
you may not be able to completely brush
aside these people but you can
supplement with a lot of greatness
you can supplement with videos and
people and ideas and resources and
thoughts and books that make you want to
play a bigger game if you hung around
george RR martin more you would aim
higher you would have bigger goals for
yourself it's why I have this channel
it's why I had the mentor me Series in
the top ten to hang your own these
people more people you might never ever
meet in your life some people will pass
on some people you may never get access
to to get more of their wisdom their
thought process their mindset because if
you hang around people and are consuming
content of people who are thinking big
you aren't gonna want to think big - and
it doesn't mean you need to read a book
on seven ways to think big that's one
way to do it you know the how-to step by
step approach but just by osmosis just
by hanging around and watching people
thinking big it'll naturally seep in to
you to want to think bigger and do more
as well when I first started working
with Lilly and decided to take her on
and mentor her and build her up into be
an entrepreneur her big goal was to do a
TEDx talk that's what she wanted to like
I want to be a TEDx speaker I need to my
big goals of speakers I want to get on
TEDx Le Pen X is nothing TEDx is small I
mean I have respect for Ted and
everything they're doing at TEDx
conferences but but you're so much more
talented than that you have so much more
of a ceiling than just doing a TEDx and
she saw that as being like a one-year
goal or two-year goal or something off
in the future like no we're gonna even
apply right now like you were gonna
start researching Ted you're gonna look
at all the ones that are coming up and
you were gonna start applying right now
and she got her first one and she's
leaving to go
her first TEDx talk and she's applying
to more and a new goal that we created
together is for her to be the most
prolific TEDx talk speaker ever I don't
know how many people have done multiple
TEDx talks have done like three or four
I don't know what the highest is but the
goal is for her to be the highest I have
the highest the most number of TEDx
talks and so taking that goal of
something that's way down in the future
and bringing it to today taking that big
thing that you think is impossible that
maybe one day will happen and in making
it happen sooner taking the the recent
goal that you had and you just hit and
that was a safe easy comfortable goal to
hit and make it bigger it's like I don't
know how I'm gonna get there but I'm
gonna try to figure it out like when you
set yourself a target and a goal you're
much more likely to have your brain then
try to figure out okay how am I gonna
accomplish it when I set my goal this
year to hit a million YouTube
subscribers by the end of the year I had
nothing to justify that you know my
growth rate wasn't on track I would be
way short but having that as a goal then
tweaks my minds okay how do we do that
how do we up our production quality how
do we bring on better videos how do we
give more value to you guys watching so
that you want to watch more you want to
share more you want to tell your friends
about it you want to go out and more
important than go and do something in
your life in your business as a result
of watching the videos and now we're on
track we're on track for late December
but it's it's on track right and
hopefully we continue to climb and grow
and we hit it and what seemed like a
crazy stretch goal at the beginning of
the year is now achievable and so I want
the same thing for you take whatever
goal you have that you've been hitting
consistently and stretch it more aim
bigger believe in yourself more stop
listening to the naysayers and the
doubters and the haters and the small
thinking people around you so that their
evil are bad we're not you know judging
them just stop listening to them believe
in yourself more surround yourself with
the resources that build you up and make
you feel unstoppable and give you
boldness and courage and implement that
into your daily routine so that you wake
up every day and do the thing that makes
you feel bold and courageous if you did
that every day for a year just imagine
where you would be compared to where you
are right
aim higher and so the question today
today is I'm curious what is your big
goal what's the big thing that you're
trying to accomplish what's the big
impact that you're trying to make I'd
love to hear from you leave it down in
the comments below I also want to give a
quick shout out to rich rich thank you
so much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word it really means a lot to
me your support and I hope you enjoyed
the read so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love and
I'll see you guys again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso
[Music]
if you configure your life so that what
you are genuinely doing is aiming at the
highest possible good then the things
that you need to to survive and to
thrive on a day to day basis will
deliver themselves to you that's a
hypothesis and it's not some simple
hypothesis right because it what it
basically says is if you dared to do the
most difficult thing that you can
conceptualize your life will work out
better than it will if you do anything
else well how are you gonna find out if
that's true well it's a Kierkegaard
ian's leap of faith there's no way
you're gonna find out whether or not
that's true unless you do it
so no one no one can tell you either
because just because it works for
someone else I mean that's interesting
and all that but it's no proof that
it'll work for you you have to be all-in
in this game there is no more effective
way of operating in the world than to
conceptualize the highest good that you
can and then strive to attain it there's
no more practical pathway to the kind of
success that you could have if you
actually knew what success was the world
shifts itself around your aim because
you're a creature that has a name you
have to have a name in order to do
something you're an aiming creature you
look at a point and you move towards it
it's built right into you and so you
have a name well let's say your aim is
the highest possible aim well then so
that sets up the world around you it
organizes all of your perceptions it
organizes what you see and you don't see
it organizes your emotions and your
motivations so you organize yourself
around that aim and then what happens is
the day manifests itself as a set of
challenges and problems and if you solve
them properly then you stay on the
pathway towards that ape and you can
concentrate on the on the 8th on the day
and so that way you get to have your
cake and eat it too
because you can you can point into the
distance the far distance and you can
live in the day and it seems to me that
that's that makes every moment of the
day super charged with meaning that
that's how because if everything that
you're doing every day is related
the highest possible aim that you can
conceptualize well that's the very
definition of the meaning that would
sustain you in your life thinking
completely different is the key if
everyone is competing on one level you
got to think at another like for
instance like I'd always wanted to get
in television but TV is so close it was
always so crowded everyone's trying to
get in on Friday night on NBC so what do
you do when everyone I've always heard
this advice that it made sense only
recently everyone is doing the same
thing and everyone's competing in the
same room you have to think much bigger
there's a lot less competition up there
there's nobody up there actually so find
the hole to fill it you can't get my
show on TV I know I'll own a network
then I can put on it
any show that I want and how many other
people are going up for a network you
know many other people applied for that
network company it was a lot and then it
wasn't a lot a hundred people in the
whole country the whole country a
hundred people threw in an idea for
network and showed a presentation it's
not a lot of people a lot less people to
meet in this room so and you think about
that think about how can I show somebody
how can I get someone's attention
everyone else is at the festival don't
go to the festival go some do think of
something but I mean go to the festival
but think also something else beyond
that don't rely on the festival because
then you're just crossing your fingers
you got to hit it from other ways and
that promotes much bigger thinking I
always say aim high because if you aim
just at the festival you might hit it
and you might just hit lower but if you
aim really high you might still just hit
the festival but least now you got a
chance but you'll hit there there or
like why some say the moon well I choose
this as our goal and they may we'll ask
why climb the highest mountain why 35
years ago fly the Atlantic why does Rice
play Texas we choose to go to the moon
we choose to go to the moon
[Applause]
we choose to go to the moon in this
decade and do the other things not
because they are easy but because they
are hard because that goal will serve to
organize and measure the best of our
energies and skills because that
challenge is one that we're willing to
accept one we are unwilling to postpone
and one we intend to win and the others
too